Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue sur cette nouvelle vidéo.
Alors c'est un peu particulier parce que j'utilise un nouveau setup pour
enregistrer cette vidéo.
Avant je tournais avec la DJI Pocket et là je filme avec mon appareil photo Sony
et j'enregistre avec mon micro de stream.
L'objectif c'est d'avoir une meilleure qualité et pour les prochaines vidéos,
utilisez ce setup.
J'ai déjà enregistré cette vidéo sauf que je me suis rendu compte
que j'ai dû mal paramétrer quelque chose sur l'ordinateur et du coup je n'ai pas
le son.
Donc je me retrouve à refaire la même vidéo.
Je vais essayer quand même de faire une bonne vidéo.
Actuellement mon bureau n'est pas vraiment meublé.
Il n'y a pas grand chose dans mon bureau donc c'est pour ça que je filme avec
mon écran derrière
et j'ai mis une petite animation pour aussi qu'il ne passe pas en veille,
pour que mon ordinateur ne se mette pas en veille et que l'enregistrement
continue.
Mais voilà, n'hésitez pas à me faire vos retours sur la qualité vidéo et audio.
Comme c'est une première peut-être que ce ne sera pas parfait,
mais je pense qu'à l'avenir la qualité devrait s'améliorer.
Qu'à partir de janvier 2026, à partir de l'année prochaine,
je vais commencer à améliorer de plus en plus la qualité de mes vidéos.
Également, si vous voulez soutenir la chaîne,
vous pouvez aller mettre une note sur les podcasts, sur les plateformes.
Par exemple Spotify, ça permet de gagner en visibilité.
Et vous avez aussi ma chaîne Twitch et ma chaîne gaming dédiée aux jeux vidéo.
Mais voilà, aujourd'hui, je faisais cette vidéo pour vous parler de mon
apprentissage du portugais.
Pour ceux qui ne le savent pas, je m'étais fixé comme challenge en septembre
d'apprendre le portugais pendant trois mois pour pouvoir parler portugais.
J'ai de la famille portugaise, ma famille maternelle est portugaise.
Et du coup, l'objectif, c'était de pouvoir parler avec eux en portugais.
Je voulais commencer mon apprentissage le 1er octobre
et du coup être capable de parler portugais fin décembre.
Et je ne vais pas y arriver.
Je n'ai pas réussi.
J'abandonne le challenge, mais pas l'apprentissage du portugais.
Et du coup, aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de parler de ça
et de vous expliquer les raisons pour lesquelles je n'ai pas réussi mon
apprentissage du portugais en trois mois.
Alors la première raison, et la plus évidente, c'est que je n'ai pas assez
travaillé.
Quand j'avais présenté le défi, quand j'avais présenté le challenge,
j'avais expliqué que je voulais travailler une heure par jour.
Et je ne l'ai pas fait.
Je n'ai pas réussi à travailler une heure par jour.
Au début, je le faisais.
En octobre, je pense que je devais être à environ une heure par jour.
Mais au fur et à mesure, ce temps a diminué.
Et bien forcément, ça a eu un impact sur les résultats.
Pour apprendre une langue, il y a le temps qu'on passe à apprendre
et il y a l'efficacité avec laquelle on apprend et ça, ça nous donne le
résultat.
Mais du coup, je n'ai pas suffisamment travaillé
et c'est la cause principale pour laquelle je ne peux pas encore parler
portugais.
La deuxième cause, c'est que la seule langue que j'ai appris en autodidacte,
la seule langue que j'ai appris tout seul, c'est le japonais.
Et en fait, je pense que j'ai fait une erreur qui est d'essayer d'apprendre le
portugais
un peu de la même manière que j'ai appris le japonais.
C'est une erreur parce que ce sont deux langues différentes
et le japonais est très différent du français
alors que le portugais est très similaire au français.
Et du coup, forcément, ça va impliquer, ça va nécessiter une approche
différente.
Comme je m'étais fixé un challenge,
comme je m'étais fixé un objectif de pouvoir parler en trois mois,
au début, dès le début même,
j'ai tout de suite eu une approche assez théorique.
J'ai tout de suite commencé à me dire
il faut que j'apprenne beaucoup de conjugaisons très rapidement,
il faut que j'apprenne toute la théorie de base très rapidement
pour avoir un apprentissage efficace.
J'ai commencé à essayer d'apprendre la conjugaison avec ChatGPT, par exemple.
Je lui disais de me donner des verbes
et ensuite, je les travaillais pour ensuite faire des exercices.
Et en même temps, j'essayais, je créais des cartes
à partir de ces phrases pour essayer de revoir dans mon système SRS,
dans mon système de flashcard,
toutes ces conjugaisons.
Et ça, j'ai eu la même approche, en fait, sur la partie plus immersion, on va
dire.
Quand j'apprenais le japonais,
quand j'apprends toujours le japonais,
bien évidemment, les mots sont très différents du français.
Il n'y a aucun mot qui ressemble
et si on ne connaît pas le mot,
on peut difficilement le deviner.
Et du coup, le réflexe dans ces cas-là,
c'est de créer une carte de vocabulaire
dès qu'il y a un mot qu'on ne comprend pas.
et c'est ce que je faisais pour le japonais,
c'est ce que je fais toujours
et c'est ce qui est efficace pour moi, pour le japonais.
Et en fait,
je pense que j'ai un peu essayé de faire la même chose en portugais.
sur l'outil que j'utilise,
il y a plein de statistiques qui vous disent
le nombre de mots que vous connaissez, etc.
Et du coup, moi, dans ma tête,
je me disais,
en fait, il faut que je maximise ça,
il faut que j'aille le plus vite possible,
que j'apprenne le plus de mots de vocabulaire
pour que mes statistiques augmentent
pour que je puisse parler portugais.
Et du coup, quand j'ai commencé à regarder des vidéos,
globalement, je comprenais beaucoup de choses
parce que c'est très similaire au français.
Mais je ne connaissais pas les mots en eux-mêmes,
c'est-à-dire que quand on me dit quelque chose,
je peux reconnaître,
mais si je dois l'utiliser,
je ne me rappelle plus du mot.
Et du coup, à partir de ce constat,
j'avais commencé à créer un maximum de flashcards
pour en revoir un maximum chaque jour.
Et c'est là une deuxième erreur que j'ai faite.
Pour le japonais, ça c'est efficace
parce que comme je le disais,
je ne peux pas deviner le sens du mot
et j'ai besoin de ce vocabulaire
pour pouvoir écouter du japonais
et prendre plaisir à faire de l'immersion.
Pour le portugais, c'est complètement différent
puisqu'en fait, je peux déjà prendre du plaisir
à faire de l'immersion
sans même forcément apprendre beaucoup de vocabulaire.
Tout simplement parce que les mots ressemblent en français.
Et du coup, le piège dans lequel je suis tombé,
c'est de commencer à faire beaucoup de cartes
pour ensuite chaque jour passer beaucoup de temps
à revoir mes cartes
pour savoir si je me rappelle de ces mots ou pas.
Et en fait, quand je regarde une vidéo,
je vois un mot que je ne connais pas vraiment,
je fais une carte
et en fait, je me suis rendu compte
que le lendemain, quand je revoyais la carte,
ben en fait, je comprenais déjà ce que ça voulait dire.
Je n'avais pas vraiment besoin de revoir ce mot
mais pourtant, j'avais créé une carte.
Et en fait, je me suis rendu compte
que j'ai commencé à passer beaucoup de temps
à revoir mes cartes
alors que ça n'avait pas beaucoup d'utilité
et que finalement, je faisais quelque chose
d'un peu ennuyant
sans que ça ait vraiment une utilité.
Et à un moment, j'ai commencé à m'ennuyer en fait
et pour le dire plus vulgairement,
plus naturellement en français peut-être,
ben j'ai commencé à me faire chier.
Ça a commencé à me faire chier
de devoir tous les matins
revoir mes cartes
avec des phrases que je comprenais
enfin, sans trop de difficultés.
Bien évidemment, il y a des mots difficiles,
il y a des faux amis,
il y a des mots qui ressemblent
mais qui ne veulent pas dire la même chose.
Mais dans la majorité des cas,
les cartes que je créais,
en fait, c'était assez facile à comprendre
et le lendemain, quand je révisais,
je ne sentais pas le besoin
de continuer à mémoriser ces mots.
C'est tout l'inverse avec le japonais.
Le japonais, parfois, je crée des cartes
avec un mot et chaque jour,
je le revois et chaque jour,
j'ai du mal à m'en souvenir.
Là, c'était complètement différent.
Et du coup, je me suis rendu compte,
enfin, au bout d'un moment,
j'ai commencé à passer de moins en moins
de temps à apprendre le portugais,
tout simplement parce que ça m'ennuyait.
Je pense que mi-novembre,
fin novembre,
j'ai commencé à me dire
que je n'allais pas réussir le challenge,
que je n'allais pas réussir
à parler portugais en trois mois,
mais que j'avais toujours quand même
envie d'apprendre le portugais.
Du coup, je me suis demandé
comment faire en sorte
que je passe plus de temps
à apprendre le portugais.
Comment faire pour, voilà,
essayer d'apprendre le portugais
quand même de manière efficace.
Et en fait, je me suis dit,
moi, ce qui me fait plaisir,
c'est d'écouter du portugais,
de regarder du contenu,
de faire de l'immersion,
et je n'ai pas besoin
d'avoir trop de vocabulaire,
je n'ai pas besoin
d'avoir trop de fiches,
de cartes de mémoire,
tout simplement parce que j'arrive
à bien, entre guillemets,
à m'en sortir,
juste avec l'immersion.
Et du coup, c'est ce que j'ai fait.
J'ai commencé à faire moins de cartes
et à essayer de chercher
plus de vidéos YouTube.
J'ai commencé à regarder Avatar
en portugais sur Netflix
pour essayer de me reconcentrer
sur ce qui me plaît vraiment.
Et pour l'instant,
j'ai l'impression que ça marche.
Déjà, je suis plus motivé
à passer du temps
à apprendre le portugais,
à faire de l'immersion.
Et en même temps,
je vois que je commence
à un peu avoir des réflexes
à force de faire de l'immersion,
un peu avoir des structures de phrases
qui reviennent régulièrement.
Alors, bien sûr,
il y a sûrement un moment
où je vais devoir repasser
sur des choses plus théoriques.
Peut-être qu'à un moment,
je vais avoir besoin
de faire de la conjugaison
tout simplement parce que
parfois, quand je fais de l'immersion,
ou même le soir,
quand je lis Harry Potter en portugais,
je ne suis pas toujours capable
d'identifier le passé,
le présent, etc.
Donc ça, je vais sûrement avoir besoin
de refaire un peu de théorie.
Mais en attendant,
j'ai l'impression d'avoir un peu
repris goût à cet apprentissage
et de m'être un peu
libéré d'un poids.
Et ce n'était pas tant une pression,
ce challenge,
c'était plus pour le fun.
Mais je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait,
l'approche que j'ai eue
n'était pas la bonne.
Et même, voilà,
même si je ne réussis pas ce challenge
et même
si je ne vais pas pouvoir parler
portugais à la fin du mois,
je vais continuer mon apprentissage
et
ce challenge a été,
ce défi a été très intéressant
pour
d'un aspect
plus méthodologique,
on va dire.
je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait,
il n'y a pas une méthode
unique
pour chaque langue,
pour toutes les langues plutôt,
mais que voilà,
il faut essayer de
comprendre un peu
les différences
qu'il peut y avoir.
Et je pense surtout que
quand on commence
à faire quelque chose
qui ne nous plaît pas,
quand on commence à faire
quelque chose
qu'on n'aime pas,
il faut faire attention
à ce que ça ne nous dégoûte pas,
à ne pas s'ennuyer
et quitte à revenir
sur quelque chose
qui nous fait plaisir,
quelque chose
qu'on aime faire,
même si ce n'est pas forcément
le plus efficace.
On a tendance
à réfléchir
à quelle est
la meilleure méthodologie
pour apprendre une langue,
mais il ne faut pas oublier
à s'amuser,
à prendre du plaisir,
parce que ce qui compte
c'est de continuer
et c'est de ne pas s'arrêter.
Donc voilà,
je pense que je vais
m'arrêter là,
la vidéo est un peu plus courte
que celle précédente,
mais là,
celle d'avant,
elle faisait peut-être
18 minutes,
donc en tout,
là,
ça doit faire
35-40 minutes
que je parle
en boucle
sur les mêmes sujets,
donc je vais m'arrêter
là pour cette vidéo.
Si vous avez aimé,
n'hésitez pas
à laisser un like
ou un commentaire,
et également,
n'hésitez pas
à me faire vos retours
sur la qualité vidéo
et audio,
et j'essaierai
d'améliorer ça
pour les prochaines fois.
Merci d'avoir regardé
jusqu'au bout,
j'espère que la vidéo
vous aura plu,
et je vous dis
à la prochaine.